Welcome, everyone,
I am Felicia Day,
and this is
The Witcher: Unlocked,
where Netflix Geeked
gives you an exclusive look
into the shows you love.
Today we're talking Season 2
of The Witcher,
and what a season
of storms it was.
(grunting, shouting)
♪
So, what does destiny
have in store for us?
Well, we'll get reacquainted
with our Season 1 favorites.
Yeah, you're about to try
and kill my kid.
(laughter)
What did you call me?
As well as sitting down with
the new faces of Season 2.
I said to Lambert,
"What the hell was that?"
And he was like...
"They're basilisks, Coen."
(laughter)
We're gonna be deep-diving
into the finale
and discussing, oh yeah,
that ending reveal
with the showrunner herself.
That conversation will all
be laid into Blood Origin.
And you're really
getting spoiled today
'cause we also have
some deleted scenes to show you.
-What happened?
-Now, I dare say,
the time of the White Chill
is nigh.
Before we venture further
into the Continent, be warned.
Spoilers abound.
Best tread lightly, hm?
♪
Let's kick everything off
by looking at
our heroes' journeys.
We are sitting down
with the cast of The Witcher
to discuss where
these beloved characters
ended up in Season 2.
Joey Batey,
the one and only,
who plays the beloved
Bard Jaskier.
Anya Chalotra, who plays
the masterful sorceress
Yennefer of Vengerberg.
Freya Allan,
also known as Princess Cirilla,
or just Ciri to her friends.
And, of course,
the White Wolf,
our Geralt of Rivia,
Henry Cavill.
Hello.
Okay, welcome, Witcher family.
I literally got chills
when I saw you all on screen
together for the first time.
Now you're in my chairs.
There's chills again.
How was it to finally shoot
scenes together?
Henry, let's start with you.
Uh, well,
most of the partnership
was between Freya and I
when it came to the season,
and enormously enjoyable.
I mean, we had one
very, very brief scene
-in Season 1.
-Yes.
And so, it was nice
to actually get
into the Cirilla/Geralt
relationship.
A long journey
but an enjoyable one.
Yeah. Freya?
Yeah, I was really
looking forward to it,
because we had one scene.
And also, I swear,
like the majority of it
got kind of cut as well
as an add-on.
So, yeah, no,
it was so exciting.
I was really intrigued
to kind of see
how we were gonna create this
relationship between them,
because, you know,
it's something
that people
are really waiting to see
and is then known
for becoming so close
and like a father and daughter.
So, yeah, I just couldn't wait
to, like, establish that.
Well, you absolutely
accomplished it.
It's a beautiful arc
over the season.
Anya and Joey, you got
to work together as well.
How was that?
-Finally.
(laughter)
Yeah, we did.
I loved it.
He's a hoot.
(laughter)
No, also,
I got to work with Ciri.
And, you know, we developed
a trust with each other outside,
so I was really excited
for this relationship
because we hadn't, you know,
worked together.
We'd been--we'd, you know,
gotten close in Budapest,
but we hadn't had that time.
And Eamon as well,
you know.
Yeah, I got a text from Anya,
I think,
when the scripts landed,
and we were just punching
the air being like,
"We get to act together,
this is so fun."
-Yeah.
-That's wonderful,
the charisma
between you two is so great.
To the White Wolf himself,
Henry, it is just amazing
to have you here.
Let's talk about Geralt's
relationship with Ciri.
It's really the beating heart
of the show.
How has this bond changed Geralt
as a character?
I'm not too sure
if it's necessarily
changed Geralt
as a character.
Geralt has an instinctual desire
to protect,
as we see in Season 1
when he's telling Roach
about the first monster
he killed.
He's talking about protecting
someone against other people.
Throughout his life,
he has then tried
to fight this instinct,
and, ultimately,
the instinct
ends up winning
a number of times,
and that ends up getting him
into more trouble.
So this is actually more like
an unlocking for Geralt.
She's the key to allow him
to really be
who he has always wanted to be.
Freya, you had
an action-packed season.
New family,
new Witcher powers,
not so many runs
through the woods.
I don't know,
were you disappointed in that?
(laughter)
No, I was very relieved, yeah.
It was long-awaited
to get to finally actually,
yeah, pick up a sword.
Absolutely,
and you were wonderful.
Anya, Yennefer had a lot of
difficult choices this season,
especially after the loss
of her magic,
which I personally
was very devastated about.
-Yeah, me too.
-Yeah. How did you--
Imagine how Nilfgaard felt.
Oh yeah.
(laughter)
You should see the other guy.
They were literally devastated.
(laughter)
How did you feel
about the choices she made
with regard
to Geralt and Ciri?
Ooh.
How do I feel about it?
I kind of went through
the motions, you know,
with Yennefer,
kind of moment to moment.
In hindsight,
she made some rash decisions.
But I think, you know,
she didn't know, you know,
how to deal with the brutality
of the world without magic,
so, you know, her decision
to sacrifice Ciri
was the right one
in the moment.
And that's the thing
about this show,
is like there's no--
I don't know,
just it's up
to the audience
to kind of figure out
what's right or wrong.
And it's the beauty of kind of
exposing so much of a character
is you get to see why
they make a certain decision.
Joey, let's talk
all things Jaskier.
We see him with his
fancy new alias this season,
the Sandpiper.
If we include Dandelion
from the book,
so, what,
you have like three names now?
-Yeah.
-Well, what's that about?
(laughter)
Yeah, Lauren,
what's that about?
(overlapping chatter)
I think I'm gonna get
a new nickname per season.
Oh yeah? Okay.
The Knife.
You're not allowed
to pick them.
(laughter)
How is it exploring a new side
of your character this season?
He's way more emotionally
vulnerable this season.
I think in Season 1,
I was doing--
we were working so closely
together,
and he had this, like,
boyishness,
like a joy in him,
this kind of light
to a lot of the darkness
that you were just
talking about, Henry.
And he often felt like
it was his job
to brighten a room.
And we get to see that desire
kind of really tested
in a world that is
incredibly dangerous.
And for the first time
in his life,
he's getting the bejesus
kicked out of him
and he doesn't have his best
friend to come and help him.
And he's willing
to put his life on the line
to--to, you know, finally do
something good with his life,
-do something morally good.
-Yeah.
And that was--that was
the biggest treat for me.
I got to see this textured,
detailed character
that Lauren was so keen
to bring to the show.
Yeah, but that scene
where Geralt comes
to get Jaskier in the jail.
That was so much fun
to play.
Ugh, it was such a good scene.
Freya, we really dig into
Ciri's family tree this season.
Obviously, Ciri doesn't know,
but Freya, I would like
to know your reaction
to the big Emhyr reveal.
Was that a jaw-dropper for you?
-It was.
-Yeah.
Did you know about that reveal
in Season 1 or was that just--
-No, no, I didn't.
-Wow.
To be fair, that gets revealed
in the books right at the end,
and there's no way
that, like,
that--that we couldn't
keep that a secret
for longer than two seasons.
-Absolutely.
-So, I--it had to happen.
We talked a lot
about story and character,
but I would really like
to just touch upon the costumes
because they were
so incredible this season.
And I would love to just hear
how they were to wear.
Anya, why don't we start
with you?
Oh, yeah, well, I've got
amazing--amazing costumes.
I mean,
whenever we start a season,
I get to try them on,
and I'm like,
"Oh, wow,
I can't wait to wear this.
I'm gonna feel so good."
And--and then
they're covered with mud
and they're like probably
like 10 times heavier
because I--I'm probably
in an aqueduct.
So, yeah, they're not as fun
to wear then.
I mean, with all the physical
stuff that we have to do
and kind of how flexible
we need to be with our bodies.
And we don't--I don't really
wear corsets as such,
but I'm kind of sucked in
to my costume,
so they're not as fun
to wear then.
But Lucinda,
the costume designer,
you know, made sure
that we did have room
this season to kind of do
everything that we need to do.
Everything was, you know,
all the demands of the show.
So, she's--she's brilliant.
Yeah, she was amazing
because she, like,
really allowed me to--
'cause I had kind of
quite a clear vision
of what I wanted her main,
like, Witcher look to be.
So I kind of
wanted her to have
this kind of rough tomboy
kind of feel to it,
like she just got
scraps of clothes
and put them together.
But then, like, she also
wears this kind of corset,
which I think kind of
added a femininity to it.
Which I think it kind of
reflects the story
in terms of Triss coming in
and kind of her trying
to embrace that side of her
as well as this more
kind of dirty fighter
that she's also become.
So I kind of, yeah,
I don't know,
that was something that
I really enjoyed,
like, creating with her,
and she really allowed me
to, like, be a part of it,
-which was so nice.
-Yeah, that's fantastic,
you got to kind of develop
that for your character.
'Cause I think
it's really important, like,
you're wearing them every day,
and so you have
to kind of feel
like it works
for your character.
Yeah, I can imagine
a lot of people
are gonna be cosplaying
that outfit,
because it is feminine
but at the same time tough,
and, yeah,
it's really wonderful.
Henry, let's talk
about Geralt's family.
So, we kind of meet
his chosen family this season.
The Witchers,
Vesemir, Nenneke.
How would you like to explore
this family moving forward?
Is there anyone you particularly
want to spend more time with?
It's--it's a tricky one,
really, because--
and it's also tricky,
I mean,
defining them
as chosen family.
Nenneke, I think, is chosen,
but being left at the doorstep
of Kaer Morhen
and forced to become a Witcher
doesn't feel that chosen.
Okay, okay, technicality.
To be true to the books,
I think there is--
there's a chance to explore
the Nenneke relationship
a little further.
Of course, I would love to work
with the Witchers some more,
but it all depends on
how much the story allows.
I'm a huge fan of the books
and staying loyal to them,
and--and it's--it's about
making sure that story happens
without too much
in the way of diversions
or side things going on
to muddy the waters.
Geralt seems torn between
two worlds this season.
He's got the Brotherhood
and fatherhood.
How is he balancing his loyalty
to the Witcher brothers
and his role
as Ciri's protector?
Yeah, he was sort of put
in a bit of a tricky spot
with that one.
(laughter)
It's--it's definitely
a fine line to tread.
I hope he manages it.
I hope we manage to convey it
in a certain way.
But he has made the decision,
as I was saying earlier,
Ciri is this key to unlock this
nature of who he truly is,
and so he's going
to hold onto that.
And as a responsibility,
he will--
he will take care of her,
even if his brothers
want to kill her.
-Yeah.
-Which is quite extreme
-a scenario.
-Yeah.
Well, at least at the end
of this season,
it turns out well.
We don't know
about future seasons,
but that--
we'll get to that later.
And I'm hearing all this
and I'm like,
"Sorry? What?
What's going on?
Who wants to kill me?
Not another person."
(laughter)
Joey, we get a sneaky reveal
at the end of the season
when we realize Dijkstra
has been your benefactor
the whole time.
I am really hyped at the thought
of you sharing the screen
with Graham McTavish
and Cassie Clare,
they are fabulous.
Do you see trouble
for Jaskier in Season 3?
I don't think we can--
I think we have to assume
he's gonna be
fairly constantly in trouble,
no matter what and no matter
who he's hanging out with.
But the idea of working
with such amazing actors,
I mean, I'm--
I count myself so lucky
that I get to turn up
every single day
and work with
amazing actors anyway.
And this family,
this Witcher family
is growing ever bigger
and ever stronger,
and so, yeah, I love turning up
and seeing what's coming.
And I'm pretty sure
that--that I'm gonna have
to really work quite hard
to hold my own
if someone like Graham
is gonna be acting opposite me.
I'd probably
just forget my lines
and sit in marveled awe
at this man.
But, yeah,
I'm excited to see what comes.
You are brilliant.
You'll be perfectly matched.
Oh, see, he looks after me.
-Don't you worry about that.
-Yeah.
And you're lovably disheveled,
you know,
like that's a lovable thing
about you.
Lovably disheveled.
(laughter)
Can we--I'm gonna
put that on my CV.
(laughter)
That's another t-shirt idea
right there.
(laughter)
Anya, Yennefer had
a really tough time this season.
She had to hang out
with Cahir a lot.
That must have been kind of
awkward, character-wise.
The show really lives
in this wonderful gray area,
so do you think
the alliances
with some of the antagonists
of the series
have kind of changed
what she thinks
about good and evil?
Ooh, good question.
Hm, yeah, I think putting
these two characters together
was a very exciting choice.
They've really challenged
each other in so many ways.
For Yennefer, her perspective
definitely changes
through this season.
She matures a lot and,
you know,
definitely becomes
less selfish,
because the situations
she finds herself in,
kind of she's had
to consider things more,
like she's less kind of
rational without magic.
And, yeah, she comes
to a more selfless place
at the end of this
because of her--
the new relationships
in this season.
Yeah, it's a beautiful arc.
Now, we're on Netflix Geeked,
so let's talk about what you
guys personally geek out about.
Henry, let's start with you.
Specifically whicher universe
or just...
-I mean, just anything.
-Oh, my goodness.
How long have you got?
You've got so many and I've got none.
Yeah, I was like, how much time do we have?
Listen, I'll sit here
all day listening.
-Ruling out The Witcher.
-Yeah, not The Witcher.
I mean, the easy answer
is Warhammer 40,000.
That is my--my jam.
I have been into it
since I was 10.
What's your army at the moment?
-Custodes.
-Ah.
I've--I'm going--I'm going
Necrons next time.
Necrons? Okay.
All right. Cool.
Were you into--
were you into this before
or is this a new thing?
Let's just assume
that anything nerdy
I've been doing
for a good 33 years.
Oh, wow, we can talk for hours.
Yeah, so, yeah, this is--
that's my jam
and that's the stuff I do
in my free time.
That's amazing, that's amazing.
I'd love to see your armies,
your collection.
-Do you paint them yourself?
-I do, yes.
-That is so cool.
-Yeah.
Is it?
(laughter)
It's cool when you--
Cool in a certain world, yeah.
I like painting,
there you go,
so I think
I'd really enjoy that.
It's so therapeutic.
I think--I think
you'd be surprised.
Yeah, it's actually
really satisfying.
So is that your geeky thing,
is painting?
It could be,
Henry might get me onto it.
Otherwise, it's--
oh no, my geeky thing
is probably cooking--
like watching cooking videos.
No, no, no, that's wonderful.
Listen, I like watching people
renovate houses.
I don't care, I'm shameless.
I love cooking as well,
so that's probably why.
Anything about cooking.
But the painting thing,
you could bring some--
this is what you need to do
in your trailers
on the off-time
during Season 3,
you paint minis and you just--
-We don't have off-time.
-What's off-time?
(laughter)
Off-time? Yeah, yeah, yeah,
off-time?
(overlapping chatter)
Yeah, can we bake that
into the schedule? Off-time.
It'll be like lunch hour
and then painting time.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Right on the call sheet.
Henry's painting time.
Freya, are you gonna
join them in to paint
or do you have another--
Oh, I love painting,
yeah, yeah.
Art is like my--no, I actually
genuinely love art, yeah.
I do--I do geek out
about that.
-Yeah.
-I was gonna say Harry Potter,
but, yeah, art sounds cooler.
I mean, sorry,
Harry Potter's great.
Harry Potter's--I'm--yeah.
-Well, yeah.
-I don't know,
-there's a bunch of people.
-I mean, it's different
kind of realm, isn't it?
But I'm gonna be
definitely watching
all of them at Christmas.
I know, it's a--it's a good one.
You have
a Luna Lovegood quality,
and she's my favorite character,
so, okay.
Okay, Witcher family,
reading glasses on,
because we are gonna
talk about the books,
the source material
behind the show,
Andrzej Sapkowski's
epic stories.
Bookworms will know
that Blood of Elves
is the season's main reference,
but we actually open
with a short story,
A Grain of Truth.
Henry, you've been a fan
of the Witcher universe
-for a long time.
-Mm-hm.
Was this a story
you were excited to see?
Yeah, from the books,
I really loved that story.
It was a story
of perspectives
and forced scenarios
and senses of guilt
and redemption.
And it's obviously
a subverted version
of Beauty and the Beast,
but done in such a masterful way
in the books.
There's so much nuance
and so much complexity.
And the answers
are never quite
what you think
they're going to be,
and your hero
doesn't necessarily make
the choices
that you would make,
but they are still
potentially ethical
and moral choices.
And it's always up
for discussion.
That's why I say it's always
about perspective.
And that's what I loved about it
in the books so much.
It's an extraordinary piece
of writing.
And what was it like to film
along Kristofer Hivju?
-'Cause he was with the--
-Absolutely amazing.
I love that man.
He is--I mean, aside from being
such an extraordinary energy,
he is--he is just beautiful
and an amazing talent.
He was playing Nivellen
in such a large character
kind of way,
but then right at the end
when the curse is lifted,
he busts out
this Shakespearean performance,
and it is beautiful.
And it just--it just--
it shows the quality
of that actor,
that he can embrace
this larger-than-life,
kind of fun character,
and then deep down
he's still got
this extraordinary
soulful performance as well,
which he's not trying
to force upon anyone.
He's not saying, "No, no, no,
but wait, wait, I can do this."
He's just waiting
for his opportunity,
and then he's like, "And here
you go, ladies and gents."
And it's--
he's an extraordinary man.
And kind and intelligent
and lovely to spend time with.
Yeah, it was so funny
shooting this scene
at the table,
because it was just--
just us three,
and we've just got food
just flying out of the sky.
And you never know
how it's gonna land,
so you can imagine
that that was like--
like just completely absurd,
really.
-Food everywhere.
-Yeah.
Your reactions were so funny
but so serious.
It made you really love
the character
that you've seen running in
the woods for a whole season.
And you're like, "Oh, she's
really funny and charming."
And it just really humanized
Ciri in a wonderful way.
Yeah, it was really great.
Freya, Ciri and Geralt
often spent more time apart
than together,
in the books and in the series.
Was there a particular scene
that you really loved
Ciri and Geralt
being together for?
Oh, yep, it was one
that actually you said
should be put in, right,
the one in episode one
where we're by the campfire
-at the end.
-Yep.
Yeah, so that
was Henry's idea
to like have
something there,
which I think
was such a good idea.
And, like, honestly,
that was--that was one of my--
I don't know,
it was something--
something about it
was like we--
I don't know,
I don't know what it was,
we just connected.
I mean, your performance
is brilliant in that,
-it's absolutely stunning.
-Thanks.
But I think we ad-libbed
most of that scene.
They ended up cutting it
as scripted anyway,
but there was genuine feeling
there.
We were talking to one another
as performers in character,
and there was real feeling.
It was Geralt
telling the story of--
he was being a paternal
or fraternal figure
in such a way
that Ciri felt safe,
despite the fact that
they had just gone through
this horrible thing where
terrible mistakes had been made
and it could have gone
so horribly wrong,
-but it felt honest and real.
-Wait, which--
what campfire scene
are you talking about?
Because I think I'm talking
about a different one.
The one right at the end
of episode one.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Same one.
-Oh, right. Sorry.
Clearly remembered it
very differently.
So, there's two--yeah.
(laughter)
It all blends together.
No, something you said
made it sound like
it was the one before.
-Sorry.
-No, it's the same.
We are talking
about the same campfire.
You guys, you all win Emmys
around every campfire.
-So many campfires.
-Yeah, so many campfires.
Some of them reshot
as well, so...
Yeah, exactly,
I've gotten lost in them all.
Now, if you know the books,
chances are you know
the "Dear Friend" letters
between Yennefer and Geralt.
They are a moment of comedy
that really sums up
all the dysfunction
of the relationship.
They're very funny
but not very romantic.
We don't see the letters
in Season 2,
but we do get a nice nod
toward them.
Let us take a look.
Geralt, do you know
what to do with this?
-Sorry.
-Ciri.
Sorry.
This is my...
You're so good in this.
...dear friend.
"Dear friend."
This is Yennefer.
You're Yennefer.
And you must be his...
Child Surprise.
♪
Oh, you're so mean.
Yeah, to be fair, you don't
really have much right
-to be pissed off.
-Exactly.
You're--yeah, you're about
to try and kill my kid.
(laughter)
What did you call me?
Anya, Henry, and Freya,
in the books,
your characters have this
very tricky relationship,
as we saw,
and in the show it's the same.
Anya, you want
to sacrifice his kid,
you hold a knife
to her throat.
Like, how do you think
they feel about--
-Happy family!
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
-Saturday night in my house.
(laughter)
It's just like Monopoly, right?
Yeah, exactly.
How do you feel, like,
they feel about each other
at the end of the season?
(overlapping chatter)
-It's--I mean--
-I don't know.
-It's tricky.
-It's a tricky one.
I mean, it's a fairly extreme
set of circumstances
to come back from.
I think we're--yeah,
we're gonna have
to play with that
-a little bit.
-I think we'll have
to figure that out
in Season 3, to be honest.
It's--I mean,
it's pretty extreme,
so it's a tough one
to forgive.
It's gonna take
some real work
and some nuance
and some complexity...
All right, okay,
I've gotta work.
(laughter)
Yeah. So, Anya,
where do you see
your character going
in Season 3 and beyond?
It's habitual, isn't it?
She's how old,
and she's lived
the kind of life she's lived,
and, you know, the rules
that she lives by,
and that's the end,
and she doesn't trust nobody,
and it's gonna be hard
to just delve into
a new way of being.
There are certain--
she might have learned
to consider things more,
but in the moment,
in such a kind of
violent world,
you know,
you've kind of just gotta
look out for yourself as well.
So, I don't know,
it's gonna be difficult.
I think whatever happens with
the storytelling in Season 3,
Anya's gonna knock it
out of the park.
She is extraordinary with
what she does with Yennefer.
The subtlety in her performance
is mind-blowing.
Like, you are top-notch.
Jaskier and Yennefer get
more screen time this season,
another great dynamic
from the books.
What's your favorite thing
about working alongside Anya?
Well, I mean,
to echo your thoughts,
I mean, I think there was
various different moments
in one of our scenes
where I forgot my lines,
which is not, um--
which is pretty rare for me,
because if I forget my lines,
which is--I never do,
but I tend to ad lib anyway
and improvise
and find my way back.
But I was just in awe
of your performance,
and so, I would quite often
be so wrapped up
in the way
that Anya's stillness
and often in the silences
can do so much
that I was just enraptured,
that I then went,
"Oh, crap, it's me,
it's my line,
I'm supposed to talk now."
And there was
a couple of moments like that
where it made me feel--
it reminded me
how grateful I am to be
working with just
such amazing people,
because, you know,
that's why you get up
in the morning, really.
And we got to have some--
she's the only one
I can't make laugh on set.
It's gotta be said.
Henry corpses, drop of a hat.
-Yeah.
-Really?
And will get his revenge on me
and will make me corpse,
but Anya,
when she's Yennefer,
she's Yennefer,
and she's unbreakable,
she's indomitable,
and that's--
so, Season 3,
that's my objective.
I'm gonna try
and get you to break.
Gonna learn how to juggle.
Exactly!
Yeah, it's a dream,
it really is,
and I'm looking forward
to Season 3
and seeing how
all of these, like--
this is the first time
Ciri and Jaskier have met.
I mean, two best pals
have just made up, and, yeah,
where does weird Uncle Jaskier
fit into this dynamic
that you strange people
have got going on?
It's gonna be fun.
I'm sure you're gonna
make me corpse.
(laughter)
-For sure.
-Thank you for answering
all of my nosey questions.
Now let's treat the fans
to a deleted scene.
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
Ciri?
♪
-Geralt.
-What happened?
I saw it.
♪
-Ciri.
-Where is she?
You can't protect her.
Just tell me
where she is!
She'll destroy us all.
I saw it.
You can't stop it.
You can't stop it!
Anna's acting you
off the screen there, Henry.
-Yeah, yeah.
-She's so good!
Yeah, that really
spooked me out.
Why was that deleted?
I don't know, I couldn't--
So many stories to tell.
To treat the Netflix Geeked
audience--you guys.
As promised,
that was the exclusive,
never-before-seen clip
from Season 2.
It showed us the aftermath
of Triss and Ciri's Dol Dusza,
a spell intended
to reveal Ciri's power
that doesn't quite go
as planned.
Um, Freya, what did you do
to Anna Shaffer,
'cause that seemed
very dramatic.
Uh, yes, um, well...
she was strangled,
and I did watch,
but I was shouting for Geralt
to come and help out.
So I tried.
-Yeah. So it's his fault.
-Yes.
Yes, where were you?
Always my fault.
Henry, it's been great
to see more of
Geralt's relationship
with Triss in Season 2.
Although this scene
didn't make the final cut,
I imagine seeing Triss so upset
had an impact on Geralt.
How do you think he views
Ciri's very scary power
by the end of the season?
Um...well, I think
he's always known
there's something special
about her.
From the very beginning
of the season,
if she can see the future,
then there's something
which isn't just standard.
She's not the standard
young lady.
And so, I think it's a matter
of just working out how--
how great a power that is.
And the true development
of Geralt this season
is him being able to recognize
that he can't do this himself.
He requires outside help,
and that's a wonderful
reflection from the books,
when he wrote to Yennefer
the "Dear Friend" letter.
That is where Geralt grows.
He becomes this idea
of going,
"Sh--" uh, don't say that word.
Um, "Darn!
I can't do this myself.
And so, I need to call upon
all of my friends who can help."
Before I say goodbye
to all of you,
one final question:
favorite moment filming
Season 2, and why.
Let's start with you, Joey.
Favorite moment, crumbs!
Um, I think it was
probably actually--
what sticks in my mind
is my first day of shooting
after the pandemic.
Just coming back,
and I was--
we were halfway up a mountain
in the Lake District,
and it was just
the first time that--
I guess you guys had done
a bit of shooting
before the hiatus,
and then I was sitting
around in my room
for six, eight months,
and I don't know,
it was a really--
it was a complicated scene,
and there was
an awful lot of dialogue,
and I was just
freezing my pants off
in a lake in the middle
of January, whenever it was.
Looking ripped!
Is that all you did,
sit-ups the whole time?
I just didn't eat.
(laughter)
It's not that hard, uh...
But yeah, that was
really, really fun,
'cause it was the first time
I'd seen you in a while,
and it just felt like
coming home again, you know?
Just all the pals,
all your friends and colleagues
that you've not seen in so long.
It just--yeah, that stayed
with me for a while.
It was so wonderful.
Anya, what was your
favorite moment?
Um, my favorite moment was
probably the aqueducts.
I loved working with
the team that I did--
Eamon, Kevin, Jamal,
it was a really special scene.
-Freya?
-Um, I would just say
all the times when it was
me with all the Witchers.
Like, I just--I just found
that dynamic so funny.
Like, me amongst all these,
like, 6-foot-2 men.
(laughter)
Just, like, little me
in a white dress.
There's just, like,
something about it
which was hysterical,
and so,
I felt like
I could just tease them all,
'cause I was in that sort of--
I don't know.
They were like
my older brothers,
all of them.
Yeah. And it really called back
to that Knucklebones scene
we see, like, in the very,
very beginning of Season 1.
You really have come
your tomboy way.
Yeah, exactly.
And Henry,
what was your favorite scene?
Um, it's--I mean,
tough to say favorite scene,
to be honest.
Tough to say favorite moment.
But I--I think
my favorite moment--
or my favorite time was
during the Lake District.
It was so stunning up there.
It just felt like a hobbit
was gonna walk around the corner
every five seconds.
And--in a good way.
(laughter)
I loved it up there.
I love location work,
and I feel you can really draw
from the environment around you,
and we're in
a fantasy show like this,
and you can really
transport yourself there,
especially if
you're looking that way
and all you have is
another character in costume
and you can't see
the camera crew or anything,
and you're saying,
"I'm here.
I'm existing within it."
And that stuff is extraordinary.
Thank you so much
for joining me today.
I feel a lot more magical
having spent time
with all of you.
Next, I have three strapping
Witchers joining me,
so I'm going to need some room
on my chairs.
♪
(blade clangs)
(coughs)
♪
Hello, Witchers.
Thank you for being here.
Let's give you all
a proper introduction.
Yasen Atour,
who plays Geralt's
Witcher brother in arms, Coen.
-Thank you.
-Paul Bullion,
who plays the gruff
but lovable Lambert,
known to his friends
as Lambchop.
The wisest of Witchers,
Vesemir,
is played by the brilliant
Kim Bodnia,
and of course,
she's a true Witcher at heart,
our showrunner,
Lauren Schmidt Hissrich.
Thank you so much
for being here.
All of you, I have
so many questions for you,
Lauren first.
Thank you for introducing
so many new Witchers
to the universe,
only to brutally murder them
in Season 2.
-(laughter)
-That was awesome.
Why did you do that?
I mean, so much of Season 2
is about the fact that, uh...
is the Witcher brotherhood over?
I mean, that's really what
Vesemir's character
is dealing with all season,
is this emotional sense of,
"Is this the end of life
as we know it for Witchers?"
So, of course,
we had to kill more.
We had to make it
more painful for him.
-Thank you.
-Sorry.
(laughter)
We just wanted to make sure
that we were really
driving home that point,
that the Continent is
constantly changing,
and is there a place
for Witchers anymore?
You clearly have
a love for expanding
on the Witcher universe,
both in Season 2,
in Nightmare of the Wolf anime.
It's amazing, watch it if
you haven't seen it, audience.
So talk us through
how you established
the Witcher characters portrayed
by these lovely gentlemen here.
What was important to capture
with each of their characters?
So we really went
back to the books
for all three
of these characters,
and the most important
thing to me is that
the brotherhood felt like
individuals that were
part of an entity
and not just an entity.
So it was really
important to me,
when Geralt goes back
to his childhood home,
that we understand that
he has different relationships
with all of these gentlemen,
and they have different
relationships with him.
There's jealousy there,
there's love there,
there's disappointment
there at times,
and then we wanted
to make sure
that those relationships
carried over to Ciri.
Um, Paul,
we see you helping Ciri
with her Witcher training
a lot this season.
Talk to me about
all those obstacle course scenes
at Kaer Morhen.
Did you enjoy
watching Freya suffer
as much as Lambert loves
torturing Ciri?
Because you loved it a lot.
It was my favorite thing
to film, definitely.
And my relationship with Freya
was full of laughter,
so we were able to kind of
laugh our way through it.
But I was just
very impressed by Freya
in that whole sequence.
I'd look up,
I'd see her stunt double
lining up the shot,
and then I'll be
chatting away to Yas,
and I'll look back up
and I'll go,
"Oh no, wait--it's Freya."
Like, she was just
so brave and consistent
in everything that she did
that sequence.
And yeah, I was like, "No,
that's not her stunt double.
That's Freya hanging
in a harness,
throwing herself around."
Like, it's just
very impressive, fearless,
and yeah, my hat's off to her,
she really is brilliant.
Yeah, and you know,
that quality of love
underneath the gruff
sort of toughness
really made your character
likable in a way
where I think
it could have gone bad.
People could have been, like,
"I don't like that guy.
He's being mean to her."
But really, those layers that
you add in your performance
really brought out
a sense of mentorship.
Oh, I appreciate that.
Thanks for your kind words.
I just...I always feel
like people,
they're not just bad.
They behave like that
for a reason,
and it normally comes
from a place of insecurity.
So I spoke a lot about
why Lambert is the way he is,
a bit of
an avoidant personality.
He likes what he likes,
he doesn't really like change.
And Ciri really
challenges Lambert
in how he reacts to things.
She doesn't go anywhere.
You know, he's used
to having people back down.
He's a big, gruff Witcher.
So if I say,
"You don't wanna do this"
or "You shouldn't
wanna do this,"
you expect someone
to back down.
But, you know,
Ciri being Ciri'll say,
"I'm not going anywhere.
I want to be a Witcher.
I want to do
what a Witcher does."
And I think
he's not used to that,
so it really challenges
how he reacts
and how he sees things,
and that's why I think Ciri is
such an important character
to Lambert, I think.
Yeah, she really pushes
everyone's growth a little bit.
Uh, Yasen, if Lambert is
the pain-in-the-neck brother
to Ciri,
you are definitely the kinder,
more considerate sibling.
We see Coen take Ciri
under his wing in Kaer Morhen.
Do you think Coen's caring side
goes against
the typical Witcher stereotype?
What I find fascinating
about that question is,
throughout the show,
throughout Season 1
and Season 2,
we hear that Witchers
don't have emotions
and it goes against everything.
But what we see is
something completely different.
You know, we follow Geralt
searching for this girl
throughout the whole season,
and then we see his love.
And then,
we meet Vesemir
and we see the love
that he has for his children,
you know?
And it's always
strange to me.
We hear it, but what we see
is completely different.
Kim, I was super excited
to see that anime
and get to know a little bit
more about Vesemir's back story.
How is it playing
such a character
with a rich back story
like this?
Thank you for doing that,
because you told me
when we were shooting
that you wanted to make--
this is a family story,
and we're going deeper
into the emotional stuff,
and we're gonna tell everybody
who Vesemir was
when he was young.
I was so happy to see it
when it came out.
It was so fun to be young
as Vesemir.
I almost forgot
how much fun I had.
(laughter)
And-and-and I was very,
very, very proud to see
that it was so well-made.
I love manga drawing
and the music,
and the voice of his,
the timing,
and connecting with
American and Japanese styles
was incredibly good.
So I was so happy
that I was allowed to see that.
And did you see it
before you acted on--
or did you see it
after filming?
I saw it when it came out,
like you guys,
so it was after I had been
doing the job for Vesemir, yes.
And I think, you know,
what you said, Yas,
is really, really important,
which is that Witchers are known
to not have emotions,
which is something that
humans have kind of concocted
so that they can treat
Witchers poorly.
But Witchers have taken on
that mantle,
because it allows them
to do their jobs
without really caring
about any effects.
They can just go in
and kill and say,
"I do it just for money,
no other reason,
and I can leave."
And what I think we explore
with Vesemir's character
is just how not true that is.
And there is this history
in Vesemir.
He is the keeper
of Witcher history.
It's something that's explored
in Nightmare of the Wolf
a lot more,
but we wanted
to continue it here,
and I think
one of my favorite scenes is--
and you'll know
the one I'm talking about--
it's you and Freya,
it is Ciri and Vesemir walking
through the Kaer Morhen lab,
and we hear Vesemir's retelling
of the deaths of the Witchers,
and why suddenly he thinks
that Ciri could be their savior.
And it's that type of optimism
that is really important
to Vesemir.
Eskel's death in Episode 2.
-Yes.
-It was very traumatic.
Can you explain your decision
to kill him off so soon?
Because people want to know.
Yes, people definitely
want to know.
Um, a couple of things.
Well, we--we knew we had to kill
someone in that episode.
We knew that we wanted
a monster to enter Kaer Morhen
and have something to do
with Ciri,
and both Geralt and Vesemir
and the brothers realize
that bringing this girl
into their Witcher keep
is going to fundamentally
change things.
And in all honesty,
the very first version
of the script we wrote
was a brand-new Witcher
that we'd never met before,
we'd never heard of,
and all of a sudden,
we were like,
"Oh. Our audience
is going to meet
Coen and Lambert and Eskel
and John.
Who's going to die?
John is going to die."
So we thought about it
really hard,
and I know that there are
fans who love Eskel
and who feel like,
why would we do that?
But honestly, his death is what
changes everything for Geralt,
and I think it propels
Geralt's need to figure out
what's going on with Ciri
and to do it fast,
because he knows that he has--
he's gonna risk losing her
and his brothers if he doesn't.
And we really just
wanted to motivate
that character journey for him.
Yeah. Well,
you don't kill somebody
unless people care about them,
right?
-It's true.
-It's an honor, right?
-That's what they tell you.
-Yes.
Because as an actor,
you love to hear that.
Also, it keeps us on our toes,
because now, we're like,
"No one's safe."
Absolutely.
You're scrolling
through the PDF,
"Am I dead? Am I dead?"
Every time I got
a script through,
I was going,
"Ohhh no..."
(laughter)
-It was like, "Noo..."
-And I'd get a phone call
as well from him.
"Hello,
have you read anything?"
Well, you guys survived,
and the audience cannot wait
to see more of you.
So a lot of fun
went down at Kaer Morhen,
but it built up
to what we could call
the monster match at the end,
Witchers vs basilisks
vs Voleth Ciri.
Talk us through shooting
that epic fight together.
How were the basilisks on set?
Were they just super divas?
Oh, I loved it.
I loved it because you're
doing something so epic,
and you know
that it's gonna look epic.
But essentially, you've got,
like, stuntmen in spandex
operating puppet heads,
foam puppet heads,
all in bright green.
So I sometimes would giggle,
because I would catch myself
trying to be
all stoic and serious,
and then,
there's a guy in green spandex
in front of me.
But then you know, like,
when I saw it in ADR
and I was like,
"Woo! Okay, great."
But it was brilliant.
And, you know, long days,
but we were able to--
I think everybody was just
so hyped to be doing it.
It was lovely.
Yasen, had you ever done
that kind of fighting before?
-Not like that.
-Okay.
Not like that.
I remember I had a small kip
before we went to do
one of them.
The first time, actually,
that they were on set, right?
-Yeah.
-And I was...I woke up,
and I was still in a daze,
and I was, like,
checks and everything.
I walked onto set,
and like you said,
I just saw two, like,
green condoms just...
(laughter)
...just staring me in the face,
and I was still, like,
trying to just kinda
wake up a little bit.
I thought, "What on earth
is going on here
with these big heads?"
And they were like,
"We're gonna fight that."
And I was like, "All right."
And then I said to Lambert,
"What the hell is that?"
He was like...
I just went,
"They're basilisks, Coen."
I was like, "Okay."
Kim, you had so many
wonderful dramatic moments
during those fight sequences.
How do you ground yourself
in the reality of your character
when all these--I mean,
they are kinda silly things
are happening on set,
but you really have
to find your reality,
and these kind of
ridiculous things
that the audience
will never see,
but that's what you're
experiencing as a person.
How do you ground yourself?
I love the illusion world.
I love to visualize everything,
and they're so good today
that you can see everything
on iPads, what's going on.
But, I mean,
you are in a room that,
as Lauren said,
is built one to one,
so you really get the illusion
how big these monsters are.
Also knowing,
Lauren told me,
"We need your emotional stuff.
Come on,"
and you just gave me
more and more to work with,
it was, like, scary!
The last fight is scary,
it's so scary for me,
it's like, why?
Why didn't I see that come?
Well, it really grounds
the whole sequence.
I mean, it's not only
spectacular visual-wise
but also emotionally.
There's so many wonderful
culminations of the season.
And we really wanted that.
We really wanted
to put that in
as a statement,
because it's not normal
you see so much feeling
in such a big fight,
you know,
because it has to go fast.
I remember when you put it
together, and saying,
"These characters have to show
the emotional stuff into it,"
so it's like a break.
It's like you stop time
to go into our emotional stuff,
and that was incredible,
as an actor,
to have the opportunity to--
then you couldn't let it go,
you had to follow it.
It's like you're fighting
and it's going so fast,
and you really don't know
what's going on,
and then it stops,
time stops!
(mimics explosion sound)
And you have all your time.
-It's so wonderful.
-It's so crazy!
Was there a specific challenge,
Lauren,
in crafting that finale that
you wanna show the audience?
I mean, I can't imagine
it was easy in any way,
but what was
the biggest challenge?
Um, there were so,
so many challenges.
I mean, COVID,
let's start with that.
But no, I mean, I think
Kim kind of landed on it,
which is,
I think that so often,
epic battles lose
their emotionality,
and yet, what we learned,
honestly,
through our fight sequences
in Season 1,
is that without changing--
if a battle doesn't
change a character,
if a fight doesn't
then it's not worth doing.
And Kim is absolutely right.
So much of a battle
is about frenetic pace,
is about making sure
that it looks cool,
and yet, constantly,
we'd be stopping on set
to say, "No.
We need to land on Vesemir
in this moment.
We need to land
on Lambert and Coen
as they're realizing
that these monsters
are coming into their home,
and that shouldn't be able
to happen."
So it really was
about timing it all out
and asking
these brilliant actors
to trust what felt like
a weird rhythm on the day,
that we would be able
to build it,
and I think, I mean, honestly,
I think it's the biggest thing
we've ever done
and one of my favorites.
It's incredibly epic,
and because those
emotional things were in it,
you remember it more.
Kim, Vesemir's most pressing
concern throughout the season
is continuing
the Witcher way of life.
In the final showdown,
we sadly saw a lot
of Witcher deaths,
so do you think Vesemir
has given up on his plan
to use Ciri's Elder Blood
to try to make more Witchers?
No.
(laughter)
No, definitely not.
I'm thinking about it
all the time,
even now.
It's so grounded in me
that we have to continue
going on,
especially now when monsters
are really taking over.
There is a reason why we are
here in the Witcher world,
you know, and it's not getting
less necessary to have them now.
So if we really need
a light in the darkness
and a hope,
we should get back now.
We can't wait.
It's like,
and this Fire-fucker,
what the fuck, you know?
He's still--he's a pain
in the ass for me, you know?
I was like, you know,
that's why I'm crying
in front of the fireworks,
what the fuck?
-I mean...
-Yeah.
Well, I can't wait to see
those story points come to life,
especially you
and the Fire-fucker.
At last, what would you two
like to see
from Lambert and Coen
in the future?
You have your opportunity,
the showrunner right now,
pitch your Season 3 ideas.
Okay, Lauren, open mind.
-Okay.
-Okay, I want you to think
fantasy meets sci-fi,
so basically,
Witchers and space.
We've actually got something
for you.
-Oh God.
-Like, literally we have
a script/treatment.
-Okay.
-And it's called
Coen and Lambchop,
Episode 1.
No, no, this is ser--
like, this is not--
this is not funny,
otherwise we'll go to Disney.
-Okay, okay.
-As simple as that.
-We're meeting Disney next week.
-Please, keep an open mind.
-Okay.
-Read it. Vesemir survives.
I'm not sure about Geralt
and Yennefer and everybody else.
Jaskier is in it.
He turns into a lizard, but
we'll come back to that later.
I see words, "lizard,
rare cell disease."
-"Twin sister"?!
-Yes!
On the planet Bantil, yes.
Give me that,
I'll hide it for you
to awkwardly throw away later.
(laughter)
-We tried.
You tried, and I admire you.
Every actor in the world
admires you right now.
(laughter)
Thank you so much,
it's been such an honor.
Lauren, I'm just gonna keep you
a little bit longer.
-Thank you, Witchers.
-Thank you.
♪
Kill them both!
(shouting, swords clanging)
♪
Time for another deleted scene!
You can't say
we aren't spoiling you.
Let's check in with the mages
of Season 2
and a clip from Aretuza.
(fire crackling)
(door closes)
You came late to
our fold, Vilgefortz.
Born of a prostitute,
abandoned in a sewer,
your magic shaped
by the ignorant druids
who picked you up.
Impressive, really,
how high you've managed to rise
above your station.
Perhaps that depth
of life experience
honed my instincts,
gave me the hunch
that saved your ass.
And so even-tempered.
You really think
you're qualified
to lead the brotherhood?
A bastard
who never attended Ban Ard
and clearly doesn't respect
our code of ethics.
Well, all mages are equal
before the law.
Oh, now, now.
Some are more equal than others.
I'm referring to the banned use
of fire magic, of course.
I was there.
I know what she did.
Then you also know
there's always a cost.
The flames
should have destroyed her,
yet she was untouched.
There's something
unnatural in her.
And there's something unnatural
in how entrenched
your protégé is with Nilfgaard.
Istredd is loyal.
He was the first to inform us
of Yennefer's lineage.
Even you can't be stupid enough
to believe your own rhetoric,
that her Elven Blood
is a threat to us.
Then what about her rage,
her tempestuousness?
♪
Then again,
you understand those
all too well, don't you?
♪
Ooh, all attention!
(laughter)
So, Lauren,
you know all the secrets.
I'm gonna ask you some questions
you probably can't answer,
and I'll just have
to deal with it
by crying myself to sleep
tonight.
Can you please, please, please
tease anything
about the moves Vilgefortz
is gonna make in Season 3?
No!
-I said please!
-You did say please,
but what was so interesting
about this scene in particular
is that we have talked a lot,
as a writers' room,
about how to roll out the
information about Vilgefortz.
We did know that,
in Season 1,
he kind of appeared
out of nowhere,
and that's because he has
a sort of deep history
that we don't know about.
It's just, we started to lean
into it this season
and then ultimately we decided
it's way too soon.
So you'll just have to wait,
you'll have to watch Season 3.
I have so many questions
about the finale,
and can we start by talking
a little bit
about Voleth Meir for a second?
She is not in the books.
It was quite a finale.
So where did this creature
come from?
So, I can answer that
in two parts, which is,
Voleth Meir herself,
the "Deathless Mother,"
she's based on the mythology
of Baba Yaga,
and one of the reasons that
we chose specifically Baba Yaga
is we found that it was
a monster
that basically every culture
has a version of.
One of the things that we love
that Sapkowski does
when he finds his monsters,
when he creates his stories,
is he pulls from lore
all over the world.
He was a traveling salesman,
so when he started writing
these stories,
he had all of these different
inspirations to pull from,
so we always think about that
when we're creating
new monsters.
Now, why did we create
a new monster?
So, Blood of Elves,
I have to say,
was terrifying to me
in terms of adaptation.
I found it so much more
difficult in some ways
than Season 1
and certainly more difficult
than what I know is coming
down the pike
because it's a book that's a lot
about character relationships
and character movements
but not a lot
of forward-propelling action,
and I think our fans
of The Witcher expect
sort of an active rollercoaster
for eight episodes.
So we started to talk
about how to introduce
a season-long villain,
not just the monsters
that Geralt is fighting
in every episode,
and furthermore we talked
about how that villain
could start to tie together
Yennefer's stories,
Geralt's story, Ciri's story,
without them all being,
you know,
on screen together yet.
So, obviously, Voleth Meir
comes in and out
of all of their worlds
and then collides in the finale.
That's interesting you say that
about, you know,
the forward momentum of the book
not being there,
but really it's about weaving
a tapestry of characters
who are intertwined
in such amazing ways.
The intricacies
of where the storylines
are going in and out,
it's just so wonderful,
and by the end, you have
this incredible feeling
of wholeness, of "I cannot wait
to see where all of them go."
Now, let's talk a little bit
more about the other big bad,
the Wild Hunt.
Now, this is gonna be such
a huge talking point for fans,
as you probably know.
Talk to me about bringing them
into this season
and what you're teasing
with the promise
that Ciri "belongs" to them.
Right, so, the Wild Hunt
is notoriously
not really introduced
in the books
until the Time of Contempt,
which is honestly
my favorite book in the saga
and I cannot, cannot wait
to adapt it,
but because the Wild Hunt
is so familiar
to so many of our fans--
video game fans, honestly,
The Witcher 3--
we started to plant the lore
of the Wild Hunt
as early as the pilot.
You know, Eist actually refers
to the Wraiths of Mörhogg,
and we get the sense
that they are this omen of war.
You know, in Season 2,
Nivellen, you know,
talks about like, basically,
they precede doom.
"A portent of doom," he says.
And so we wanted to make sure
that by the time we met them,
honestly, we were
thoroughly scared of them.
So we started playing
with the idea of what are they?
We know from the books
that they are spectral,
but we also know
that by the time
they actually kind of interact
with Ciri more,
there's a bit more tangibility
to them.
So that's what we wanted
to start playing this season,
which is this idea
of these ghosts in the sky.
Some people believe in them,
some people don't.
They're more just this,
you know,
urban legend, if you will.
And when they tease
that Ciri belongs to them,
what we're hopefully gonna lead
viewers to believe
is that there's
a lot more history
of Ciri herself.
Her lineage, her bloodline,
things that we know now that
Calanthe has hidden from her,
perhaps some connections
to Lara Dorren
that we have teased
this season as well.
So all of that is gonna come out
in the wash next season.
Well, I love the fact
that you say you planted--
I saw that, I mean,
honestly, this show,
the more you watch it,
the more I admire
personally and as a fan--
I'm sure fans do too--
how you have planted these seeds
that come to bloom later,
so much later,
and they're even just tossed off
and yet they come--they are
a whole storyline later.
It's so wonderful for fans.
It is, most of the time,
on purpose.
Sometimes just
the most amazing coincidence
that we're like, "Oh, thank God
someone said that in Season 1.
We're gonna make that work."
Let's take a look at some
of the other characters
from this season.
In our finale, we have
the Head of Redanian
Intelligence, Dijkstra,
scheming with Philippa Eilhart.
So, these characters bring
this really awesome dynamic
to the screen,
especially 'cause they seem
to know everything about Ciri--
stalkering much.
(laughter)
Can you hint
at what you're setting up
with these two characters?
Absolutely, so, you know,
in Season 1,
we really started to set
the political chessboard.
So, Cintra was obviously
very important
and we knew that Nilfgaard
was going to be important,
and then we've heard
of these other kingdoms.
We see Temeria a little bit
when Geralt fights the striga,
but we haven't really delved
into one of the kingdoms
in the way that we are going to
with Redania.
And so, I wanted, again,
to start teasing
who these characters were.
We don't know a lot
about them this season
and certainly we don't know
a lot about them personally.
They're more just
sort of adversarial
for Tissaia specifically,
and when Dijkstra appears
at Aretuza this season,
there is the sense
that he is there
kind of reading the room,
and Tissaia is smart enough
to know it.
He's just come with gossip,
but she knows
obviously there's something
that he wants from us,
and that thing is Ciri,
of course.
And what we wanted to do
was make sure
that by the end of the season,
we understood
just how many people
are after this poor girl.
You know, she feels safe
by the end of Episode 8.
She has found her family,
she's with Yennefer,
she's with Geralt,
and it's like everything's
gonna be okay,
except it's not,
it's really not.
(laughter)
Yeah, whenever you have
a happy moment
between characters,
you're like,
"Oh, that's gonna go badly
for them next season,"
and in such a delicious way,
I'm sure.
Yes, because it's one
of the things
that we found most important
about what Sapkowski did
in the novels, right,
is that every single character
has some sort of underbelly.
It's not even necessarily
a dark underbelly,
but it's a secret
that they're hiding,
it is a personal agenda,
and what I love is that
we really get to play
with those shades of gray.
None of our characters
are black and white.
Everyone, you know, none of them
are all good or all evil.
We really get to play with
different sides of characters,
-which is delicious.
-It is delicious,
and it busts a lot of clichés
of the genre.
Yeah.
Lauren, it's a great reveal
in the books
that Emhyr is Ciri's dad.
Great reveal. Can you talk
about how you built up to it
and why you wanted to end
the season
on this specific twist?
So this is probably the thing
that we debated most
in the writers' room, and I have
so many different versions
of the finale that spoiled
very different things.
-Oh.
-And the truth of the matter is,
we were basically divided
as a writers' room.
Are we ready to let
the audiences in on this secret,
especially when our characters
don't know yet?
And that's always
sort of dangerous
because you could feel
like your characters
are behind in the story,
or what we're going to lean into
is the suspense
of the audience knowing
what's coming,
and how and when
are our characters
going to figure it out?
But let's be honest,
that shift,
bringing that story up,
it's logistical
more than anything.
We really wanted
to start to understand
the Nilfgaardian Empire,
and there's no way
to understand it
without digging into Emhyr
a little bit more.
This also goes to, you know,
the two sides of characters,
right, which is,
throughout the first season,
Nilfgaard is the evil empire,
and yet I don't think they think
of themselves as evil.
They think they're doing
the right thing,
so we wanted to start to reveal
that side as well.
And as soon as we see
Emhyr again,
we're going to know
that he's Duny.
We talked about recasting,
we talked about
aging him up so much
that you didn't recognize him,
but those actually felt like
we were going out of our way
to hide a secret
from the audience
that it felt like
the right time to do it,
and now we can actually dig
into Emhyr
and why exactly he wants
his daughter back so badly.
Absolutely, yeah,
he's a fascinating character.
In the final lines
of the season,
it's revealed
that Emhyr himself
ordered the killing
of Francesca's baby.
Can you explore
his motives for us?
What is his evil, evil deal?
'Cause it's not good.
It is not good,
and that's something actually
that we're delving into
a lot more in Season 3,
so I don't want to give that
away too much.
-Okay, okay.
-But what that really did for us
is it allowed us to show
just how far
Fringilla and Cahir
were willing to go.
You know, Fringilla has made
a friend in Francesca this year.
One of my favorite scenes
is them realizing
that they like being partners.
There's no like
forward story movement there.
It really is just about
two women actually realizing
that they could be partners
and not competitors.
So that was super important
to me, and yet realizing
that Fringilla's sort of quest
for power
may start to outweigh her desire
to have this friendship
and how is she going
to do both?
So we thought that was a really
interesting undercutting
of what we have seen
of her journey this season,
and then she needs to redeem
herself in Season 3.
Yeah, that was
a very impactful scene,
It was wonderfully Bechdellian.
(laughter)
We last properly saw Duny
in Season 1
where Geralt claims
the Law of Surprise from him.
Can you help us
fill in the gaps
of what Duny's been doing
between Season 1 and Season 2,
other than obviously
some kind of glow-up?
(laughing)
Serious glow-up.
Um, again, that's something else
that we'll talk a lot about
in Season 3
because, obviously,
he has a plan.
We see in Ciri's Dol Duzsa,
we hear sort of the story
that Pavetta
was going to get on a boat,
Duny was going
to bring baby Ciri
under the cover of darkness,
and they were going
to sneak away.
The reason being is because
people around their family
were starting to realize
that Ciri, there was something
a little bit bigger and better
about her,
returning to the idea
of Ithlinne's prophecy
that, again, is one of
those things like the Wild Hunt
that we've been teasing
from the very beginning.
And for book readers,
they know that that trip
on the boat didn't end
exactly as planned,
and that is the night
that Ciri's parents died,
expect for, clearly...
-"Died."
-Pavetta died and Duny did not.
And Duny then had to start
to form a plan
with a...with a new partner.
That's what we're gonna dig into
in Season 3.
Now, I have a question for you.
If you noticed,
there's one of my favorite
little sort of
Easter egg moments
in Episode 8, which is,
Ciri is in the illusion fantasy
and she is starting to realize
that she has her choice.
She can either stay in the past
with her family
or she can move into the present
toward her new family,
Geralt and Yen.
Obviously that's what she does,
and to demonstrate that,
her family starts disappearing
into dust
and going back to their form,
you know, which is dead.
-They were dead.
-Yeah.
Did you notice that,
in the final shot,
Pavetta turns to dust
and disappears
but Duny does not.
Does not, he didn't.
Yes, yes, I did notice that!
That is because he is not dead.
Wow, and so, that's,
I mean, it's so wonderful.
It's so wonderful!
Ah, I love this show so much.
Okay, speaking of looking ahead,
this season, we also dipped
a lot into the history
of the Continent
with the Monoliths
and the Conjunction
of the Spheres.
Since we're getting the prequel,
Blood Origin,
before Season 3,
how do you plant the seeds
for the new series
in Season 2?
Do we have seeds, Easter eggs?
You absolutely have Easter eggs.
So, one of our goals
has been to understand
how this Continent came to be,
and it's one of the reasons,
actually,
that we chose to make Istredd
a bigger character
than he is in the books.
We love the story,
Shard of Ice, in the books.
We love that eventual
love triangle over Yennefer,
between Istredd and Geralt,
but as soon as we introduced
Istredd,
Royce Pierreson was
so delightful in this role,
and we realized that we had
a character that we could use
to explore the history
of the Continent
'cause he is a scholar,
he is a historian,
he's a researcher,
and it was really helpful
to put a voice to the things
that we really needed
our audience to understand,
like what are these Monoliths,
why are they here,
what are they doing?
Obviously he and Geralt have
a sort of in-depth conversation
about them this season
revealing that there is
much more to the Conjunction
of the Spheres than we thought.
That conversation
and a couple of other things
throughout the season will all
be laid into Blood Origin.
Wow, I cannot wait.
I mean, the cast for that
is so incredible.
When you mentioned
that one scene,
I have to tell you,
one of my highlights
of the whole--I know
this isn't about me, but...
-No, tell me.
-One of the highlights
of the whole season
was Geralt's reaction
to hearing that he loved--
I have never seen an actor
do so much with so little.
There are so many
beautiful moments,
but that one, oh my gosh.
I just couldn't--
I couldn't deal.
And to me,
it's like the two men,
that moment where Istredd
calls her Yenna...
-You know Yenna?
-Yenna...
And they just face each other
and they both know
in that moment that we have
our own names for her,
we obviously have deep intimacy
and love for her and...
Yeah, I don't mean--
I can't wait.
I don't know
if it's gonna happen,
but if the three of them meet,
oh boy!
(laughter)
Anyway, I could go on forever,
but, Lauren, thank you so much
for letting me geek out
with you over your show.
As a fan, I can't wait
to see what comes
for the Witcher franchise.
Thank you so much,
this is so much fun,
and I love talking
about the finale.
I haven't been able to at all.
It must be a little bit
of relief, yeah, I know.
It's really fun for fans
to see this,
but I just really urge everyone,
watch it again
because not only are
the Easter eggs there
that Lauren just mentioned,
there are a ton more.
I mean, just even
with the graphics
coming in for the beginning
of each episode being different
and thematically tied
to the episode,
it's just fantastic,
it really is.
So, yay, thank you so much.
Thank you!
Join us in 2022
for more episodes of Unlocked
where we'll break down your
favorite geeky Netflix shows.
Until then, let's remember
the true hero of Season 2:
Roach, gone but never forgotten.
♪
Enjoy your last walk
across the meadow
and through the mist.
♪
Be not afraid of her,
for she is your friend.
♪